eu suspeito que a maioria das pessoas
não gosta de lavar louça como eu disse
eu tenho raiva de lavar louça não gosto
de lavar louça a louça tem um poder
mágico se multiplicar começar a aumentar
o seu lado você começa a lavar a louça
de repente você se distrai olha pra
esquerda não tinha mais nada aqui
repente em bandejas e pratos
é uma coisa horrível quando alguém faz
um bolo grudado aquele negócio naquela
tigela
você sabe que você está com muita dor de
coluna porque vai demorar pelo menos uns
30 minutos pra você arrancar todo aquele
pedacinho do bolo de açúcar grudado nele
na verdade eu acho que realmente as
pessoas não gostam de lavar louças
aborrecem com isso é importante dizer
isso é importante dizer que as pessoas
se aproveitam de você quando você está
lavando louça
elas ouvem aquele barulhinho o campeão
na cozinha você mora em uma república
com a sua família ea minha esposa minha
filha eu vi que eu tô lavando louça o
que não acontece
fazendo um claro mas ela ea minha esposa
se aproveitar como ela sabe que eu não
lavo louça nunca se eu estou lavando é
tipo uma vingança de um 10 anos
relacionamento ela chega àquela tigelas
de couro e esquece de orkut com cereal
todas as coisas que mais grudenta ser
piores de lavar isso é um pouco
vergonhoso não eu estudei em escola de
londres em oxi e ela também não vou
assumir a culpa da louça sozinho e minha
esposa 2 bagunceiros
estudamos todos os métodos científicos
no desenho de estudo coisas dificílimas
na hora de lavar a louça é aquela
dificuldade que a gente vai resolver
isso em tão simples contratar alguém
para nos ajudar
então eu falei com ela por conseguinte
não vão parar com essa bagunça tudo
muito problema é que isso gera um
estresse a coisa ea louça só é só a
pontinha concelho sabella só com
desviando pela
casa é aquele monstro que vai crescendo
vamos contratar alguém
fizemos cálculos estavam não conseguir
pagar e fica um pouco apertado mas dá
certo
um dia antes a gente contratar pessoas
estavam na cozinha bem tranquila está
fazendo uma carro bem gostoso
e aí a minha esposa tem essa qualidade
assim de bolatti também chega no
restaurante ela muda de ideia mas 18
vezes que ela vai querer chega e fala
assim pizza pizza quem sabe um burro
então quem sabe uma carona a um suco não
quem sabe superar uma cervejinha não
toca na copa não faz bem não então ela
vai mudando de opinião e decidiu que
aconteceu
simples a gente ia a gente comer alguma
coisa e aceitá-lo assim não acho que a
gente não vai contratar ninguém
mudei de opinião muito caro e eu acho
que nós podemos tentar fazer isso mas
ela já havia falado isso assim umas 40
vezes ela sabia que não dava certo ele
não ia lavar loiça erótica é lógico que
vocês podem ver com aquela raiva foi
subindo a orelha vai esquentando
eu fui saindo assim da cozinha assim
respirando respirando até que eu cheguei
no meu quarto eu não falei nada no
momento
cheguei no meu quarto lá e pensei eu sou
um cientista
eu estudo mais fãs em português ele
chama de atenção plena mãe é um estado
onde mente e corpo observam a si mesmo
sem reagir sem julgar
são 30 anos de estudo é uma área envolve
neurociência as pesquisas mais rigorosas
é como você se tornar um exímio
observador de si mesmo já havia mais ou
menos 56 anos estava praticando aquele
toque ele era o momento tomado por raiva
cheguei até o quarto o coração batendo
acelerando a inspiração do que vocês
sabem que acontece quando a gente está
com raiva dela queimação que acontece
porque há 56 anos
eu estava tentando estudar aquilo pra
poder ajudar cardiopatas e usam o
sistema único de saúde são as pessoas
que não têm dinheiro para pagar para
fazer cursos sobre isso e realmente
precisam utilizar essa estratégia seu
dia a dia e eu estava como um cientista
primeiro experimentando em mim para
então poder ensinar para eles e eu
consegui observar todos os efeitos da
raiva no meu corpo o mais importante
observar sem reagir sem ser controlado
como um zumbi pela raiva a raiva faz com
a gente então enquanto cientista eu
aprendi que quando nós somos tomados por
emoções como raiva uma área do nosso
cérebro nós podemos dizer assim
grosso modo bastante primitiva ela fica
super ativada e uma outra área do nosso
cérebro mais próxima da testa ela como
que se desliga o nosso córtex pré
frontal e essa área é uma área que é
nobre e é basicamente responsável por
tomada de decisões tomadas de decisão
teste de realidade e tudo que você mais
precisa quando você está estressado
agora pensa comigo quando você está mais
interessado assaltado por fortes emoções
que você mais precisa dessa região do
seu cérebro o que acontece nessa região
ela vai se desligando e é por isso que
quando você está com raiva você faz
coisas depois você se arrepende
há como fazer acredite se estupidez onde
eu estava com a minha cabeça ea prática
de mais fãs
ela é como se fosse uma musculação hoje
nós sabemos depois 30 anos de pesquisa
era como se fosse uma musculação dessa
região do nosso cérebro e alguns anos eu
vinha fazendo essa ginástica cerebral e
naquele momento
esse estado desabrochou sentindo todos
os efeitos da raiva dentro de mim
o vulcão não só no corpo mas a minha
mente também vai lá a briga com ela está
mudando de opinião de novo de novo ela
sempre faz isso vai lá vai lá vai lá e
não parou por aí
além de ter ficado de novo sozinho toda
a louça suja já não dava direito mas eu
queria arrumar um jeito está a funcionar
isso eu tenho uma menina de seis anos
agora luz também estava no quarto toda
essa raiva ea letícia esposa para
começaram a discutir por que é clara não
queria jantar de crianças fazem isso não
quer jantar então esposa começou a você
tem que comer aquilo foi aumentando
você vai pra praia do público um caldo
de uma onda e logo você levanta em outra
onde derrubar de novo desse jeito
então tudo que o meu cérebro emite as
informações mentais eram vá até a sala
batendo forte disse len sítio e não foi
isso que aconteceu
eu observei sem reagir e eu chamo isso
de um pequeno milagre um pequeno milagre
porque é um pequeno milagre pensa comigo
e se algo está acontecendo no teu
cérebro milhões de anos de evolução
milhares e milhares é um curso muito
básico permitindo então contrariar esse
impulso é um pequeno milagre mas o texto
eu não tive que me arrepender de nada
depois eu ia me arrepender porque eu ia
chegar e evitando na sala um susto e
chorar pai gritando olha pra mim
o louco gritando eu não sabia o efeito
que tinha causado aquela mudança
repentina de opinião de última hora que
sempre acontece
eu te amo você sabe mas então vejam eu
consegui observar sem reagir o que
aconteceu como esse pequeno milagre
aumenta a situação se resolver o
professor
normalmente as coisas poderiam acontecer
a gente pior já está difícil
quando menos esperava as duas estavam
sentados entre elas haviam se entendido
eu já estava sentado na mesma hora que
eu vi o serviço não foi fácil não é
fácil observar estudo há sofrimento não
é fácil antes no corpo não é fácil ver
sua mente emitindo esses comandos que
você sabe depois bom você vai se
arrepender mas depois
eu fui até a sala as duas estavam
jantando
eu sentei com elas nós comemos ainda
estava com os efeitos ainda é claro da
raiva no meu corpo minha filha jantou
nós comemos
depois ela foi dormir e vocês pensam
sobre a louça suja eu falei então depois
o meu cérebro já não mais assaltado por
essas emoções de raiva por meu cérebro
já auto regulado por essa atividade
executiva do meu córtex pré-frontal eu
voltei a conversa com a minha esposa e
nós nos acertamos e hoje nós temos uma
pessoa que nos ajuda mas talvez essa não
fosse a solução se a raiva você é a
única solução possível e eu quero
aumentar um pouco mais esse pequeno
milagre
veja o que eu estou falando de coisas
banais lavar louça onça
os entendimentos comuns acontecem dentro
de casa família filhos
eu não estou falando
eu não recebi naquele dia uma notícia
que eu tinha uma doença terminal
eu não recebi um telefonema de alguém
falando com um familiar um ente querido
amigo havia falecido são coisas que
acontecem esporadicamente ao longo de
toda uma vida
mas eu estava falando sobre algo que
talvez seja mais urgente que são os
pequenos estresse cotidianos que vão
fazendo e vão se tornando após algum
tempo um estresse crônico que vão
fazendo com que essa região importante
do nosso cérebro a cada vez mais
adormecendo adormecendo nossa capacidade
de planejamento teste de realidade
tomada de decisão
mas se enfraquecendo e pra vocês verem
todas as idéias brilhantes vocês estão
vendo aqui hoje
nós precisamos dessa região forte porque
se nós nos tornarmos uma nação de
expressadas combinados apenas pelos
impulsos mais primitivos nosso cérebro
nós não conseguiríamos mais ver pessoas
brilhantes e nós sabemos que há um
grande problema de stress no mundo
presente
eu estou falando de algo que nos
encontra em 24 horas por dia 365 dias
por ano
pequenos estresse desafios que a gente
pode começar a utilizá los de maneira
mais eficiente a nosso favor nós nós
temos essa essa capacidade estado de
maine fãs pode ser exercitado as
pesquisas hoje nos mostram que o estado
pode ser exercitado obviamente não só
através de máquinas mas também através
de algumas outras técnicas que vêm
recebendo respaldo da ciência e vejam a
uma opção de não ser mais carregado como
um zumbi pelas fortes emoções a essa
opção por mais que você tem que
contrariar os recursos mas a tábua do
seu cérebro
o grande desafio é o seguinte nós temos
duas opções a primeira é continuar o que
nós estamos fazendo
lutando contra eles lutando numa luta
infinita ea segunda opção é recebê los
como companheiros de viagem
o movimento eventos e eu não quero eu
não quero é não quero que o sofrimento
exista alguém não tenha algum sofrimento
eu duvido que o sofrimento não encontre
ainda que minimamente alguém então a
outra opção é receber os pequenos
professores e se sim como professores
como companheiros de viagem e se a
ciência está nos dizendo que é possível
nós podemos utilizar isso a nosso favor
nós podemos
e esses milagres
ainda bem eles continuam a se repetir
pra mim e pra minha família dos meus
amigos eu convido vocês a embarcarem
comigo essa jornada
muito obrigado